to quote my own personal favorite
live-action iteration of frank castle
sometimes i wish i could get my hands on
god so the first full proper trailer for
netflix is the punisher series has come
out and huh there's there's not a lot
that i like about this and before i get
into specifics i just want to point out
a few things first of all i feel like
i'm starting to get on a string of if
not negatives at least not
enthusiastically positive stuff you know
i tried to get in there you know why I
love Gotham as a way to break it up but
you know I was much more iffy on it then
a lot of folks were and then I didn't
like the tomb raider trailer and now
this and as I it's fun to get riled up I
don't actually enjoy being in a negative
space but I need to acknowledge that
especially in regards to Marvel's
Netflix stuff I kind of am right now
because I when I actually sat down and
thought about it
Marvel's Netflix shows don't actually
have a great track record and I think I
was fooled by the fact that it started
out so strong I think we've only had two
solid seasons of really good television
daredevil season 1 Jessica Jones season
1 daredevil season 2 Luke Cage the
defenders all of these started out well
and then had significantly weaker second
halves and then iron fist was just a
mess it did actually go worse as it went
on but it started out as a mess so at
this point what I actually think about
it this is not a really strong track
record especially because it's two
victories were back at the start of this
whole thing so I will freely admit that
I came into this trailer in a more
critical headspace perhaps than some
people did and I readily acknowledge I
was looking for the red flags and I
would say I'm sorry for that but
honestly I am more sorry that Netflix
hasn't been on a downward trend or at
least has forced me to reassess them and
I now can't help but be more defensive
and not get us blindly optimistic about
it that's just where I'm at right now so
my thoughts on this thing first of all I
liked Jon Bernthal in the role in
daredevil season two I thought it was
good I thought he worked but this
trailer I could go on and nitpick about
a ton of little things that I didn't
like but really pretty much all of it
revolves around one thing and that is
what I feel is the excessive emphasis on
military and I need to be really
specific about that cuz I'm not talking
about oh he's the other military back
Frank castles always had a military
background that's actually really vital
it's really vital to the way he thinks
he processes his methods all of that
stems from that but he the this trailer
it's it's implying a military conspiracy
and I'm seeing him fight and gun down
soldiers like guys in full tactical gear
with assault rifles and everything about
that rings wrong to me to try and try
and explain why Frank Castle classically
his his wife and his child were gunned
down by the mob that is why he is in a
war against crime and organized crimes
in particular when he's not being
written stupidly but that's why the man
weighs the war on crime crime killed his
family and this trailer has it has him
safe flat out they killed my family to
get to me which first of all is a trope
that I'm just done with I'm really sick
of as a thing and now but now the fact
that he was gunning down Irish mobsters
before doesn't make a heck of a lot of
sense how was that in service of him
getting back at the military
organizations that's responsible for his
family's death I mean part of me wants
to say maybe I need to re-watch
daredevil season 2 and maybe they made
it more clear and it was a guy because I
know there were some later revelations
about the specifics of it but I don't
want to rewatch daredevil season 2 and
in any case the this shift between him
fighting the mob and crime drug dealers
you know street thugs and bad military
people it's a very different feel it's a
very different vibe part of what I
really like about
Frank and about the Punisher is what
makes him part of what makes him so
effective in his war on crime is he is
coming in with training and tactics and
hardware that the mob and street-level
crime folks aren't prepared or used to
or equipped to deal with so when he
comes in with his military tactics and
his military assault rifles he takes
them apart and that is a big part of why
he is so effective and and also the fact
that he is coming at this world that is
not a military engagement but coming at
it from a military angle when he is
written well and his stories are written
well that leads to some interesting
stuff too as there are things like
collateral damage that he doesn't take
into account sometimes you take out
somebody and then there's a power vacuum
that results because he's coming at it
with him with a soldier's mentality and
a soldiers mentality is once you have
identified who the enemy is and you're
sure that's your enemy you just take
them out that's just what you do and
there isn't a lot of room for nuance on
that because it's a life-or-death
situation once the enemy has identified
you take out the enemy but when he's
dealing with organized crime which is
not only like not on a war front
somewhere it's home territory and
there's a lot wrapped up and all that
sometimes he kicks off events that
aren't what he intended and I've always
enjoyed that dynamic about him again
when he is well written but having him
go against the military that betrayed
him I don't know not only does that not
feel like the Punisher to me that feels
like something that I've seen a lot that
I feel like I've seen that to death and
I'm immediately less interested I'm
immediately less invested and actually
my first red flag on this came up there
was a video that got put out before this
trailer did and it's sort of this action
scene and it's like it's cobbled
together from body cams on these guys
that again I don't know if they are
actually military but they're kitted out
and acting like military you know
they're all tactical and they've got
full gear and all this stuff
and while it was good
since seen don't get me wrong and the
the the fight looked good and everything
that pinged my radar right there it's
like why is he fighting soldiers and
that because I see that and I think that
that doesn't feel like Frank castle that
feels like Jason Bourne and I I don't
know if that's a good compare and I
don't mean like it's suddenly gonna be
born Chinese opera but I just mean the
guy who was betrayed by the government
taking on that government like that's
that's not Frank's story and I do
understand he's dealt with military
people he's taken on you know dictators
in foreign countries and this and that
and he's dealt with crooked military I
understand that's been there but what is
the fundamental root of what the
punishments the Punishers and war on
crime so the first season of his own
show should be his war on crime you
could do a him dealing with you know a
corrupt military organization or a
private military contractor or you know
corrupt individuals in homeland secure
or whatever like in a second season the
first season do do the fundamentals of
the character and the fundamentals of
the Punisher is man makes war against
crime street-level crime gritty crime
the kind of crime that just you was
investing New York in the 70s and 80s
when the character was first introduced
there was really only one moment in this
whole trailer that felt like a true
Punisher moment to me he's pointing the
gun at this guy on the ground who's
obviously unarmed and no longer a threat
he says what do you know about my family
the guy says I don't know anything
he says fair enough and shoots him
anyway that is the Punisher that's Frank
Castle and that's the only moment where
I really felt like that was him because
again just the whole premise and story
that this thing is selling I'm not gonna
say it can't work but it doesn't feel
right for a first series of this
character so yeah I guess that's me I'm
not in love with this trailer and I'm
not in love with the ideas this trailer
is selling and again there are other
good elements they seem to be taking
Frank's PTSD seriously which i think is
a good and respectful
thing to do I'm glad they're doing that
not trivializing it a little bit of
characterization we get on micro looks
it looks interesting and that's working
for me but these are small side things
the main core of what this trailer is
telling me the show's gonna be I'm not
that interested in this is not me saying
I won't watch the show
I'm keep an eye out for a future trailer
see how it goes what might be the
make-or-break is whether it's a 13
episode or an 8 pretty sure it's a 13
though because the like I said the the
Netflix shows aside from Jessica Jones
season one and daredevil season one have
had usually six good six seven good
episodes and then things fall apart or
if it's iron fist it had one good
episode and I don't mean it had one good
episode I mean it had one episodes worth
of good stuff spread out across 13
episodes in bits and pieces so yeah I'm
not not thrilled not excited and not
happy with the fact that that's how I
feel about it so those are my thoughts
on the trailer for Netflix is the
Punisher series what were your thoughts
on it whatever they are drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
don't forget to like subscribe check me
out on Twitter at council of geeks give
a listen to the council of geeks podcast
feed available on iTunes and stitcher I
am also one half of the punch like a
girl podcast which will be on the fire
and water network starting in October so
give a listen to those and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]